[music]
All right, let's go ahead and open up
the doors. It is straight up noon here
in Pacific time and my name is Becca
Dukes. Thank you so much for joining us
here on Daily with Doc as we're letting
people in from the waiting room here in
the Zoom room. You also are invited to
join us Monday through Friday from 12 to
12:50 p.m. Pacific time. That's 1:00
Mountain, 2:00 Central, 3:00 Eastern.
Join us at dailywithdoczoom.com.
Now folks, this program is being
sponsored by dailywithdoc.com.
This is a website that offers the good
foods bad foods list that you're going
to hear about on today's program. It's
also going to give information about Dr.
Wallik on that page, myself and the good
pharmacist, pharmacist Ben Fuches. And
it also has a store that is available on
that page. And the one of the things
that I like the best is there is a spot
that says what should I take? And it
gives a description of our core
foundation 90 essential nutrients page,
plus
the add-ons that make up the blood sugar
pack, the digestion pack, the bone and
joint pack, the athletic pack, the brain
and heart pack. Folks, we make it
simple.
Now, if you got some decline going on,
what you're going to hear today with the
questions and answers and Dr. Wallix
protocols that are going to be shared
with the individuals who bring their
questions to the table is going to be
optimal for reaching your optimal best.
We want to make sure that you got your
digestion right folks. So Dr. Wallik
also includes that to help everybody
looking for solutions to find that
solution. And then we have a team that
works with you to help you as well. If
you are referred by somebody specific,
that is going to be your point person,
the person that you will get back with
and say, "Thank you for sharing this
program with me, and I need some help.
What do I take? This is what's going
on." Or if Dr. Wallik mentions your
question here because you raised your
hand in the Zoom room and asked your
question, then make sure that you have
that chat open because Marilyn is going
to be putting in dictation of what
doctor recommends for each person and
each question that is brought up in the
program. So you can take a screenshot or
take a picture of that with your camera,
take that to the coach that you are
working with and say this is what I need
and we try to make it as simple as
possible for you. If there is nobody
that you are working with then please
feel free to give our staff a call. We
have an 800 number 855-9493377
and we also have email that if you go to
our website dailywithdoc.com
there is contact option in the menu and
you can send us an email if you prefer
to do business through emails. So folks
this program is for educational purposes
only. It is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician, but nor
are the products meant to diagnose,
treat, cure any diseases. The FDA
requires us to let you know this. And
folks, everybody is an individual.
Depending on where you are in your
health, we determine how fast things are
going to be working for you. So, give
your body what it needs. Give it time to
do what it needs to do with those raw
ingredients and you are going to get
some positive results. Some faster than
others, some it takes a little more time
and Dr. Wallik is going to be talking
about that today.
Now folks, if you have never heard of
Dr. Wallik, never met Dr. Wallik, you
are in for a treat. The doctor that we
have on Daily with Doc, he started out
as a young boy with some issues himself.
He paid attention to what was going on
around him as a farm kid. He made
changes with his own diet and was able
to correct the negative things going on
in his health and then he used that kind
of as a bouncing board. I think God used
it actually as a bouncing board in the
direction that his life was going to
take him to help humanity.
Now he went into college, got a degree
in agriculture with plant science and
soils, went into
become a doctor of veterary medicine
where that took him around the world
with one of his first discoveries as he
was working in the pathology department.
And
the story just exploded from there,
folks, as being one of the key
individuals on that expedition to save
the white rhino. He was a pathologist
and veterinarian there. And
you know, animals just weren't quite
enough. He wanted to help people, too.
So with his education with being a
pathologist and getting three postd
doctorates and pathology
and then including humans into the
autopsies
figuring out the commonalities between
the two where there was something
missing, this disease was consistent.
When there was a disease, something was
consistent and missing. He put all those
points together for us and was become
one of the founding fathers of the
science of epigenetics
which is the death of disease
transmission. When it comes to genetics,
folks, genetics, there are no genetic
diseases. Are there birth defects? Yes,
there's birth defects, but they're
nutritional deficiencies. And I'm sure
you're going to hear a little bit about
that as well.
Dr. Wallik has also taught nutrition at
the college level before becoming a
naturopathic physician and now as a
naturopathic physician in licensed in
many states. He continues his mission
and we are here as part of the crusade
to get the information out that empowers
you and communities around you as
individuals
to take a better journey on health. So
there's multiple paths you can take.
We're going to show you the path that
has solutions rather than masking up the
symptoms. So Dr. Wallik, thank you so
much for being here with us on Daily
with Doc.
I had some questions in regards to the
bone marrow and joint replacement.
>> Do you have a little
>> on that? Can you can you educate us a
little bit on what happens tomorrow and
why joint replacements would be
considered? Okay, let's go back 3,000
5,000 years ago when people used to make
bone broth. Okay, had to make bone but
they made bone broth 3,000 5,000 years
ago. Um, everybody knew that bones were
involved with structure, but some people
figured out that there's some
nutritional value uh in the bones. And
so they'd eat all the meat off of it,
whether it was chicken bones or beef
bones or lamb bones or or bones from
ducks or fish or whatever.
And then they would take [clears throat]
the bones and some of them would just
put the bones in some water and simmer
it all night and then drink the water
the next day and they got some benefit
from it. Okay? And then other people,
they would take a rock or a hammer and
they break those bones so that there's
more surface area exposed to the water
in the pot and they would simmer it and
boil it low boiling all night and they
would drink it the next morning and they
were getting very special materials from
the bone broth. Okay, these materials
are nutrients that are required to build
red blood cells, platelets uh for
preventing you know um bleeding to
death. Uh the oxygen would go into the
red blood cells and go around the body
and bring the oxygen around the body. So
that was important. And then also
the uh bone marrow uh would give up the
white blood cells. White blood cells
were kind of like the um guard dogs and
they would run around eating bad stuff,
viruses, fungus and yeast and poisons
and so forth to save the host. And uh
let's see here. uh they would also uh
the bone marrow would give raw materials
for the bones to make more bone marrow.
Okay, there's a nutrition necessary to
make more bone marrow. And the bone
marrow was so important and they knew it
before there was microscopes. They
didn't know know exactly what all was
there, but they knew there was something
special about that bone marrow. Okay.
[clears throat]
And then um
let's see here. They also um learned
that they could take the bone marrow and
and make this soup out of it and they
could heal people who had diseases and
pneumonia and skin problems and all
kinds of other things. And they just
didn't realize how important bone marrow
was. Okay. It just it it is a um kind of
like a liver. People don't realize a
liver does 50 different things. Well,
the bone marrow does more than than
that. That's does about a hundred
different things. Okay. So, it's very
very important when it comes to your
health and survival and protecting you
against many many bad things. Okay. And
then of course we have um the the whole
idea of um the bone replacements that
came later on when surgery and
anesthesia was developed. Okay. in in
later years and when surgery and
anesthesia came along, if you had pain
in your joint, said, "Well, we just cut
your joint out and put a artificial
um metal or rock ball in there instead
of the your cartilage and and bone
marrow." And so they would replace the
good stuff with useless stuff. Okay? But
it's one of those things where it was a
very very poor choice was to replace
joints. It's better to rebuild them,
rebuild them so that they could still do
their purpose. Okay? And this is what we
spent a long time. I've been doing this
for 75 years. And we see this in animals
on the farm. We see this in people like
um oh, let's see here. Our great
basketball player, Theo Ratliff. You
know, this guy is 7 foot tall and um
he's 24 years old and they took his $35
million contract away from him because
he had all kinds of stuff going on with
um his bones and his knees and his hips
and um they wanted to do a double knee
replacement. Now, when you take out the
joint, the knee or the hip or the
shoulder, you're taking out a big ball
of bone marrow along with that bone and
cartilage.
Okay. And so there was a lot more going
on behind the scenes than people knew
when they got knee replacements and hip
replacements and shoulder replacements.
Well, fortunately, um, he didn't want to
do that and they took away his $35
million contract and we met him, okay,
because of that, um, and was able to
come up with the healthy
um, bone and joint pack. Okay, this is
this is actually our healthy bone and
joint pack. And it was actually just our
our basic um program. Okay, our healthy
start pack. And then we invented
collagen. Okay, we came up with a
collagen called um what what what's our
collagen? The old old one.
>> Gluccoel.
>> Gluccoel. There you go. Glucagel. So we
added gluccoel to the plant to the um
just the um vitamins and minerals. We
added the gluccoel to it and made it to
the the bone okay bone and joint pack
and regrrew theoratas joints. He came
back played professional basketball for
11 years made a hundred million dollars.
Okay. Okay. So, that was a teaching
thing for me and many other people that
you could regrow the cartilage, you
could regrow the bone marrow and make it
work. And so, our goal is to prevent
unnecessary
joint replacements. Now, you know, on
occasion, this is necessary, but if it's
unnecessary, it's better to use the the
um healthy um start pack and the the
glucagel, the healthy bone and joint
pack, okay? And rebuild everything and
take those nutrients every day for the
rest of your life, whether you're a
professional basketball player or just a
mom and dad pushing the baby on on the
cart through the grocery store. Okay?
And so this is very very important stuff
and um you can [clears throat] save an
enormous amount of unnecessary misery,
save yourself a lot of money, add many
healthful years to your life because you
want that bone marrow making the
antibodies to protect you against
viruses, bacteria, fungus and yeast. You
want that bone marrow to help you um
maintain
um things like platelets so you don't
bleed to death. You want the bone marrow
to be there because that helps make um
let's see here red blood cells and get
oxygen all around the body. Okay? And so
people don't realize how important that
bone marrow is. Okay? It it's in there
with the brain and the heart and the
liver and the bone marrow. Okay? I put
the bone marrow in there with those
other major systems.
And so this is something that you just
have to deal with every day. You have to
do it correctly. Uh, you want to watch
things that will poison and kill the
bone marrow. Um, excess alcohol. You
know, there's nothing wrong with having,
you know, a glass of wine with your
dinner. It's that kind of thing. But you
don't want to be drinking beer made from
wheat um, every night, especially on
Friday night when you got paid. Okay?
And
the the gluten in the wheat that was
used to make beer would cause problem
because you couldn't absorb the
nutrition. So the bone marrow suffered.
Okay. So all these things kind of go
together and we were the ones that made
all those observations. Um people were
just treating symptoms with aspirin,
that kind of stuff. And aspirin was
good. Pain go away, but the problem
would get worse and worse and worse and
worse and finally uh cost you either cut
your leg off or you might die. Okay? Or
because you didn't have any antibodies
being made in the bone marrow. It's just
something very simple. An infection
would kill you. So, uh this is something
I cannot stress enough when it comes to
the importance of the bone marrow. And
then and then um when they they got the
joint replacement system, they stopped
making bone marrow soup and all that
kind of stuff. And that's when we
decided to come up with a bone marrow
replacement. Okay. Okay. And that's
where the glucagel uh came from.
>> Okay.
>> All right. So, Dr. Wallik.
>> Mhm.
>> Whenever you have joint replacement and
and how help us understand a little bit
about the consistency of bone marrow, is
it solid? Is it liquid? What I know
whenever you Okay. I've a farm kid. I
know that whenever we we put a beef in
the freezer and we cut everything up,
the bone marrow inside is solid. Is it
is it solid whenever somebody's still
alive also?
>> Oh, yes. It has a lot of connective
tissue in there and all the cells that
make the red blood cells and the white
blood cells and the platelets and the
antibodies are in that sort of web,
okay, of connective tissue,
okay? Otherwise, it would all get down
to one part of the bone. The rest of the
bone would be cavity would be empty. And
so to equally distribute um the bone
marrow so you get maximum um function
uh you know the good lord is very very
competent when it comes to these things.
Now when you look at the um mechanics of
bone marrow, not the not the actual
function of bone marrow, but just the
mechanics of bone marrow um being
equally um produced and given the raw
materials through the blood supply that
can do its job. And in all bones in the
body, whether it's the ribs, the
jawbone, the skull, normal skull, and
we're talking about the pelvis, uh the
leg bones, the armbbones, the shoulders,
shoulder blades,
they all have bone marrow.
Okay? So, you think about the
um space in your body that's devoted to
making red blood cells, for oxygen
transportation, for making platelets,
they don't bleed to death. um for making
um things like white blood cells to go
kill viruses, bacteria, fungus and yeast
and making antibodies so so kill
viruses, bacteria, fungus, yeast. The
bone marrow does an enormous amount of
stuff. Okay. And so um
the good lord was a great great
physiologist
and made us to be able to
uh not only survive but to perform in a
maximum way to instead of live to be
25 years old you live to be 125 years
old.
So help help me understand how does the
red blood cells, white blood cells get
into the blood from the bone marrow.
>> Well um they go out from little arteries
and the little arteries have space in
between the cells and walls of the
arteries.
And so all these cells seep out through
those um cells and the arteries.
Okay, they get down into the capillaries
which are very thin walls. Okay, and
it's very easy for the for the um red
blood cells, white blood cells, and the
antibodies to get through the cells that
just sort of joining together. They're
not 18 top, you know, on top of each
other and in in the when you're out
there at the ends of the capillaries.
>> So So are there blood vessels that go
into the bones?
Oh yes, the blood vessels that go into
the bones come out of the heart and the
aorta that goes throughout the whole
body. And not only do they carry blood
and all the raw materials to make blood
in the bone marrow, but also they're
carrying oxygen. They're carrying food.
They're carrying nutrients, vitamins and
minerals to the whole body.
>> Okay. I'm trying to understand this Dr.
Wallik. Okay. says, you know, not all of
us have the experience that you do when
it comes to pathology and how everything
looks within within the body. We see
pictures, you know, we see the diagrams
that basically show the major arteries
that are coming in and out of the heart
and through the body
>> smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller. It's not the big
arteries that release nutrients into and
oxygen into the bloodstream. It's the
little capillaries that are sort of the
end point of those arteries. As it gets
as they get distance from the heart and
the lungs, they get smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller. And
that's when the nutrients and the oxygen
and the white blood cells and the red
blood the white blood cells primarily
start leaking out between those cells
and and go and do their thing for the
body.
And that is just another reason why
circulation is so important because of
those small capillaries pulling the
blood or dispensing the blood all
throughout the body.
>> It's a delivery system. It's a delivery
system.
>> So then if if the blood is not healthy
and it's not getting to your
extremities, that's going to be causing
like discoloration of your toes, your
feet. you get gang green, your your toes
die, and then the doctors want to cut
your toes off.
>> Well, you know, there's a lot of people,
Dr. Wall, that reach out saying, "Hey,
I've had to have the, you know, certain
toes removed already. How can I stop
this from going on?" And so, is is that
more of a bone marrow issue, circulation
issue? They're told that it's because
they have blood sugar issues.
Okay. Well, they might have they might
have diabetes. Okay. But diabetes
doesn't cause all these diseases that
doctors are laying blame on diabetes for
all these diseases. They don't know what
else. They don't know anything about
this subject. Okay. Um you you ask a
doctor
um um what's in um
when when does the oxygen that the the
blood vessels picked up in the lungs?
When does the oxygen get released from
the blood in in the blood vessels in the
body? At what point? Is it the arteries?
Is it the veins? No, it's the
capillaries.
which totally makes sense whenever they
got that O2 sensor on the end of your
finger.
>> Okay, that's there's there's a dot
connected for me. Thank you so much for
that, Dr. Wallik. Now, our first
question, Dr. Wallik, has to do with
deteriorating discs.
Um, Carol is writing in. She wants to
know what she needs to take to get rid
of deteriorating discs, rebuild
cartilage between the discs in her back.
Um she says it's extremely painful and
they say there's nothing that can be
done except major surgery. Now Carol is
5 foot 320
lbs at 76. Dr. Wallik um and I know for
personal experience you do not have to
be 76 or even in your upper years to
have deteriorating discs.
I was diagnosed with that at 30. So,
I know what you recommended for me. What
would you recommend for Carol, Dr.
Wallik?
>> Okay, that's Carol.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Well, Carol needs to get rid of
all the bad foods. No fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat, no ran oats, no buckwheat, no
sugar, no carbonated drinks. Even the
diet drinks and carbonated water need to
go because they neutralize stomach
acids. So, you cannot absorb minerals or
digest food. And then at 120 pounds, I
wanted her to have one healthy brain and
heart pack a month, a half a dose of
everything twice a day. I'd give her two
bottles a month of the MSM. So you can
take three at breakfast, three at lunch,
three at dinner time. That's going to
support and promote maintenance, repair
of cartilage, ligaments, tendons,
connective tissue, disc bone rates, bone
itself, and bone marrow. Okay. Also help
rebuild bone marrow. All right.
And then um [clears throat] this
includes uh the disc and so forth.
So also they need the collagen peptides.
Okay, collagen peptides, the gluccoel,
uh say three of those twice a day in her
case. I would also have her take the um
I I said uh I said the glucagel, but I
also want her to have the collagen
peptides. I want her to take a scoop of
that with her morning drink and a scoop
of her evening drink. All right. And I
want her to take vitamin D3. Take
vitamin D3. Take three of those twice a
day. That'll be two bottles a month
because they're small bottles.
And [clears throat] uh let's see here.
But for the pain, I want her to take the
CM cream topically on her back, on her
knees and hips and shoulders, wherever
she has pain. It'll last for anywhere
from 3 to 5 hours. So, you may have to
apply it two, three times a day, okay?
To to be comfortable, okay? And
it's one of those things where um the
body is dynamic. It's not poured
concrete.
people and doctors doctors think your
bones are poured concrete. They don't
know that they come and go and come and
go and come and go based on what you're
eating, what not eating, and so forth.
Uh what activity you do and what
activity you don't do. Okay? And um
if you know a medical doctor looking at
this case, they would say, "We need to
call in a musician with a trombone
because she's 76."
>> Oh. 76 trombones. You're funny, doc.
>> Okay, that would be the medical
treatment. See, and there they always
talk about, okay, well, let's see if we
can give you some pain relief. You like
aspirin or some prescription drugs, and
if that doesn't work, uh, we'll do some
surgery here and you'll, you know,
you'll have to be in a wheelchair and
all this kind of stuff. And, and they
never really get to the basic root
cause, uh, which was eating gluten and
not supplementing.
Those two things together are very, very
bad. Okay. Not supplementing and eating
gluten because gluten prevents the
absorption of nutrition, what may have
been in the food and there's usually not
much in food other than some calories
and protein and that kind of stuff. All
right.
>> All right. Well, thank you so much.
>> 76 says she can she can repair all this
within weeks.
>> And you had mentioned vitamin D, which
leads me into the next question coming
from Bruno. Bruno writes in he says my
wife is 61 has low vitamin D levels
what my question well his question is
what can we do to improve that but my
question to you first Dr. Wallik is what
is the importance of vitamin D?
>> Okay. Well, vitamin D helps you
[clears throat] absorb calcium and
placement of calcium into your bones.
Okay, that's specific use your body has
for vitamin D. And you can get some
vitamin D uh from, you know, getting out
in your bathing suit and short sleeve
shirts and shorts um out in the sun. get
a sunbath, you'll get some vitamin D.
[clears throat] It's one of the first
things that they added to baby food
before we sued them in federal court and
had them add more. But before in in the
1920s when the kids are getting
ricketetts, okay, they're getting
ricketetts because they didn't have
enough vitamin D, they they would begin
to add vitamin D to the baby formulas.
They also put vitamin D3 into milk.
could you go there to the store around
the label it says vitamin D3 added.
Okay.
>> And so that was an attempt to fix that
problem and they were they were thinking
correctly but it was a minimum approach.
Okay. So what would you do to help raise
vitamin D levels? She is 162 lbs at 5
foot n Dr. Wallik.
>> Okay. Well, she needs to take give her
all the bad foods. No fried foods, no
processed meats, no oils, no glutens, no
wheat rinse, no buckwheat, no carbonated
drinks, no sugar. Um, and get a hold of
that book. Uh, Dr. W cooking without the
bad foods. 300 pages of safe recipes and
cooking methods. Okay. And it also has a
good food bad food list in it. Dr. W
cooking without the bad foods.
And then uh she needs to take um again
atund is it 162 pounds?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. 162 pounds. Yeah. I want her to
take two healthy brain and heart packs a
month. Flossing twice a day, two bottles
a month of the MSM. So you can take
three at breakfast, three at lunch at
dinner time to support and promote
maintenance repair cartilage, ligaments,
tendons, connective tissue, disc brain,
vertebra, bone rs, bone itself,
including bone marrow. Okay, most people
never get to see their bone marrow and
it's very important part of their body
physiology.
And um but also she needs to be taking
the collagen peptides. Take a scoop of
that with her morning drink, scoop with
the evening drink. Collagen from four
different species of animals. Then she
also needs vitamin D3. Take three of
those um at least twice a day. Three
twice a day. Vitamin D3 um capsules. And
um the pain in the joints will go away
very quickly. Okay. How long does she
have to do this? Forever. Okay. You need
these nutrients two or three times a day
for the rest of your life. Okay. You
can't just say, "Well, I'll I'll do it
on Christmas only." You're not going to
be in good shape. Okay, this has to be a
maximum maximum intake two or three
times a day. Okay, because you're eating
food that interfere with absorption and
all that kind of stuff. So, you want to
make sure it's getting through and into
the tissues where it's going to do some
good. You'll see some benefit. Okay.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that,
Dr. Wallik. And folks, you can find Dr.
Wallik's books at drjwallik.com.
That is d e r j w a l a c.com.
And Dr. Wallick, of all of your books,
which one would you recommend? If you
were to pick one and somebody has
questions in regards to bone health,
which one would you pick? What would be
your first pick?
>> Well, let's see. There's three. And uh
one would be let's see here rare
earthbidden cures chapter 10. Okay. Uh
the other one would be epigenetics
the osteoporosis and arthritis and the
other one would be dead doctors don't
lie.
There you go.
>> There you go.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that.
>> Those three books will give you a
college education. Those three books
will give you a college education.
Dr. Wallik, I've had a lot of college
and I'm going to be upfront and honest
with you right now. I have learned more
about the body and health and nutrition
just working with you than I ever did in
college.
>> Yeah.
>> And I, you know,
>> thank you. Thank you for that feedback.
And of course, but you're a responsible
person and you're doing a lot of reading
because you had access to those books
and things. And those books represent an
enormous amount of research in addition
to what is taught in classes because
what is taught in classes is is sort of
basic stuff which is good, but there's a
lot more involved than just the basic
stuff. Okay. As you're learning.
>> Yes. and and I'm going to kind of let
the cat out of the bag a little bit, Dr.
Wallik. So, folks, um we have been
approached to actually include Dr.
Wallik in curriculum and we're putting
curriculum together to be taught in
colleges and universities. So, that is
something that I'm super excited about.
Dr. Dr. Wallick, it's about time that
your books are being used for
the required reading and even textbooks
at the college level. So, that is a
project that we are working on
in addition to others. So, I'm looking
forward to being able to announce that
as well.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome. Thank you for, you know,
keeping me working 248, 24 hours a day,
nine days a week. Well, folks, you're
listening to dailywithdoc.com.
If you are watching the replay or you
are watching a live stream and you'd
like to join us anytime live, we are
here Monday through Friday from 12 to
12:50 p.m. Pacific time by going to
dailywithdocsoom.com.
That is dailywithdoczoom.com.
And I invite you to go to our website
dailywithdoc.com.
Sign up for our newsletter that puts you
on our list so that we uh can send you
replays or the links to the replays with
descriptions from the previous week. It
also includes the invitation to our
program so that if you want to join us
either via computer, via phone, it has
that information in the email that will
come to you as well. And if you have a
question that you would like to submit,
which is how I'm getting some of these
questions, you're welcome to submit your
question there as well. So, Dr. Wick,
let's go up to Marilyn who has a
question for a client. Marilyn, go ahead
and unmute yourself.
>> Yes. Hello everybody. Yes, I well I
actually had someone write in to the
show uh comment and they wanted to know
about herbs. They said, "Can we take
things like shillit I think it's called,
uh, black seed, sour soup tea, sour sap
tea, apricot seeds, and they have
another, they have a teac
addition to the supplements they're
taking."
>> Okay. Well, if you look at our education
brochure,
okay, you're looking at our education
brochure, okay, it has some of these
books, okay, that Rebecca's talking
about, but it also has, I believe it's
close to a hundred
CDs and DVDs, okay, going into all the
herbs that we have done research on and
use. There's we use herbs. If you look
at our we have 3,000
um we have 3,000
um products.
Okay, we have 3,000
products including herbs. A couple
hundred of them are herbs. Herbs go back
uh to the early Bible days. Okay? Uh and
they realized that some herbs could
relieve pain. They realized that some
herbs could help you sleep better. uh
some herbs uh could help you be stronger
and so forth. And so herbs go way way
back and it's one of those things where
they're still useful. Um but like
everything else, herbs tend to be like
medicine. They relieve symptoms and
pain. For instance, if you use an herb
for joint pain, is it going to rebuild
the joint? No.
Okay. instead of aspirin, it's an herb
to relieve joint pain.
And so you have to understand what that
herb is the good Lord designed it for.
Okay? Uh herbs don't take the place of
all nutrients and this that and the
other because herbs their functions
rarely provide nutrition. They usually
provide relief of symptoms.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah. I know you have that book, Let's
Play Herbal Doctor.
>> Yes.
Thank you. Appreciate it.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you so much for that
question, Marilyn. That is a great one.
And let's play herbal doctor. I've got
that right here, too. Let me go ahead
and put spotlight myself.
There we go.
>> There you go.
>> Doctor, this was actually one of the
first books that I bought, Dr. Wallik,
because as an herbalist,
it like caught my attention. I'm like,
what? I don't have that book in my
library. So, this was this was actually
one of the first books that I bought
whenever I first heard about you. This
one and then The Dead Doctors Don't Lie.
Those were my first two books. But my
favorite book, Dr. Wallick, is the
epigenetics
because that's the one that gave me hope
that all the things that I was told were
genetic. I would have to live with the
rest of my life. And we have proven that
to be incorrect. So like
>> just like the name says gen death death
of the genetic theory of disease
transmission.
>> Yeah. That that book is actually an an
abstract of the original thesis I did on
20,000 autopsies. NIH study at
Washington University in St. Louis.
20,000 autopsies. and I showed that
there were no genly transmitted diseases
and
that book is in the Smithsonian
Institute as a national treasure. I'm so
proud of that. But they sell for 25,000
to $35,000 each. So that's why we came
up with the the book Epigenetics and I
didn't realize it was going to become a
a science, but we we we wanted to get
that information out so people could
have. So it's only 25 bucks, not 25,000,
but 25 bucks. Uh epigenetics. You're
getting all the information that's in
the $25,000 book.
>> Well, and these two books right here,
Dr. Wallock, are the two that we're
focusing on as being the first textbooks
that are going to be offered in the
project that we're working on. So,
>> Oh, thank you. Yeah. See, you surprised
me. I didn't even know about that
project. Thank you.
>> I told you about it a while ago. You
just keep me so busy. I don't have time
to make it happen. So after this project
is done, then this is this is one of the
next ones. Doc, it's about time. Well,
um, Dr. Well, the next question that I
have is coming in from Tammy, and she
says, "We have a male friend, 46 years
old,
235 pounds. He's a recovering drug user,
hard drugs. He says his brain feels like
it's on fire. his fed head feels swollen
and he can't sleep. What would you
recommend, Dr. Wallik? Um, she does
mention
that he does not have a blood sugar
issue. He is a smoker. Um, and his blood
pressure
is a little elevated, but he's not on
medications for it.
>> Okay. Do we know uh how many times he
wakes up at night to urinate? Once,
three times, five times?
>> We don't know that. We need to ask that
question because the odds are he's got
um um let's see the odds are he has
osteoporosis of the skull causing this
thing going on in the brain and skull.
Okay. And so when you look at the the
brain, the spinal cord and the diseases
that go along with that, Alzheimer's
disease, MS, multiple scerosis, gamay
syndrome, Parkinson's disease, which we
believe we have found the cause,
prevention, and cure for Parkinson's
disease. A case report is at the
certified health coaches. You can get a
hold of a copy of that. It's a case
report on there's one case, a lady by
the name of Meline who was diagnosed by
uh Rush Medical Center. Okay. 11 years
in a row and we have the stack of of um
the annual physicals that say
um Parkinson's Parkinson's Parkinson's.
Well, we gave her in two and a half
months our program for these things for
rebuilding the myelin and the brain and
the spinal cord and so forth. And when
she went for her 12th year annual
physical, they couldn't find Parkinson
disease anymore. And so that's where we
did the case report
because it wasn't a study on 50 people
or 100 people. It was just a case report
of a gal that came to us after suffering
for 11 years unnecessarily.
And so any rate um Parkinson's disease,
frontal temporal dementia, uh Cryfield
Jacobs disease, ALS, Luger's disease,
all of these are diseases of the myelin,
the white matter of the brain. Okay? And
so that's why we have the I26 to go
along with the healthy brain and heart
pack. The I26 can rebuild that myelin.
And this is what we did for Meline when
she was diagnosed with um Alzheimer, not
not Alzheimer's disease, but Parkinson
disease, excuse me, Parkinson disease.
And she just recovered very nicely. And
this is going to be a big story coming
out here pretty soon uh with Meline.
We're very excited about that and um uh
we have all the information. We have uh
enough stuff here to provide it to the
world. Okay. We want to eliminate
Parkinson's disease. We want to
eliminate Alzheimer's disease. They're
all
>> and the reason it's the same deficiency.
It's the same pathology. When you look
under the microscope, same pathology.
It's just random bad luck. What part of
the brain and spinal cord is being
affected? What disease you get?
Well, and and I totally understand that.
Dr. Wallik, going back to Tammy's
friend, do you think that the drug use
had any type of effect in harming the
brain that would be causing that? And I
can also
>> when you're doing drugs, you're not
taking in nutrition. So, what you're
saying is absolutely be impacting that
as well.
>> Yes. And so, got to get rid of the bad
foods. Got to take, you know, eat well.
Dr. Cooking without the bad foods book.
Um, good food bad food recipes.
And then um, need the healthy brain and
heart pack. 230
pounds of one 235 pounds, whatever it
is. Two healthy brain and heart packs of
full thing twice a day. Uh, two bottles
a month of the MSM. You can take three
at breakfast, three at lunch at dinner
time. Um, two canisters of the collagen
peptides and scoop with that with the
morning drinks with the evening drink.
And then again the we we need to be
taking the what the
collagen
>> I26 or
>> 26. There you go. The I26.
>> Okay,
>> you got it.
>> I 26. I26 will rebuild the myelin and
all these diseases. Remember the same
pathology, the same tissue. Okay, the
myelin the brain and spinal cord is just
bad luck which part of the anatomy is
more affected which disease you get.
Okay, but it's all reversible. I26 plus
all the other nutrients we just
discussed. It wouldn't hurt to throw in
the ultimate daily classic tablets for
circulation.
And um uh don't forget the rebound or
sports drink instead of instead of soft
drinks and that kind of stuff instead of
carbonated water. Don't forget the
rebound. It's another source of 75
minerals. Red Bull only has one mineral,
magnesium.
We have 75 minerals. Which is better for
you? 75 minerals or one mineral? Okay.
>> I'm going to go with with more is
better, doc.
>> And when it comes to nutrition, more is
better.
>> Yes. Well, I promised that I would get
you out of here at 12:50. So, let's see
if we can squeeze in two more questions.
Sherry, go ahead and unmute yourself.
>> Hello. Thank you so much. We have a
question that uh has come in. If a
person does not have a spleen or a
gallbladder, what should they eat and
what supplement should they take? No
weight, no height.
>> Okay. Well, the first thing you need to
do is get the book Dr. Walsh cooking out
the bad foods. Okay. Get rid of all the
bad foods. No fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils or gluten or wheat rinse.
So buckwheat, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks, even the diet drinks and
carbonated water need to go. And then
they need um per 100 pounds of body
weight, they need one healthy brain and
heart pack. Okay? And since they have
the the gallbladder removed, doctors are
just doing something because they didn't
know what it was. Okay? They're just
doing something. And so this is why we
have the ultimate enzymes. We could take
two or three of those, say, five or 10
minutes for each meal. The ultimate
enzymes, we call it the gallbladder in a
bottle. It replaces the gallbladder that
the doctor's unnecessarily removed.
Okay. And um so go there. And let's see,
what was the other one? Yeah. Oh,
spleen. Um that's, you know, the spleen
helps with the blood. Uh it helps with
um what supports your immune system.
Okay? And so, you know, go with what we
just said. And if you want to again to
rebound or sports shrink that's going to
help with more nutrients that helps the
immune system then you know give us a
call on this individual every couple of
weeks and let us know what's going on
because this is
>> Thank you so much.
>> You bet. All right. Thank you Sherry and
Dr. Wallik. Charlotte is writing um in
regards to three children ages 21
months, 23 months and five years old.
weights are 38 pounds, 28 pounds, 22
pounds, and they each have a severe case
of hand, foot, and mouth. What is hand,
foot, and mouth for our listeners? And
what would you recommend?
>> Hand, foot, and mouth.
You got me, but it sounds like
>> it's a viral it's a viral infection, Dr.
Wallik. and it you get sores and
blisters on the hands, on the feet,
inside the mouth. It's very painful. Um,
my little guy had it probably
goodness, eight years ago maybe.
>> Okay, I only got seconds here. So, get
rid of the bad stuff. Okay, get them on
um the the um u
>> kids totty.
>> Yeah, the kids totty at least once a
day, but maybe twice a day. Kids totty.
Don't forget the EFAs. Don't forget the
EFAs. And then uh I would also if they
had pain in in their hands and feet and
neck and back, use the CM cream. But
also
you need the colloidal silver. If
there's viruses and bacteria and fungus
involved, uh colloidal silver, uh
colloidal silver, um remember I'm a
veterinarian. We talk about foot and
mouth disease. I'm
that's a totally different story. Okay.
And so this is where the colloidal
silver comes in because has no alcohol
and it won't burn and it does kill bugs.
Okay? And then if they have things going
on in their skin, rashes and blisters
and all kind of stuff, don't forget the
hair, skin, and nails, they go ahead and
take a couple of those two or three
times a day. All right?
>> Well, where they're only 20 20 to 30,
you open them up and you put in some
applesauce. This is not difficult.
>> Okay. So, they can have they can have a
full 100 pound dose at that age. Yes.
because that would what two is. Okay,
just double checking, doc.
All right. And then spraying colloidal
silver on the skin topically, would that
be beneficial?
>> Absolutely. Orally with the dropper and
then also, you know, just follow the
directions for the the um dosage, but
you can, as you say, just spray it right
over the even if the wounds are open, it
won't burn because there's no alcohol in
it.
>> All right. Thank you. Thank you so much,
Dr. Wallik. And I know that you have to
get to your next program. Thank you so
much for joining us here on Daily with
Doc. God bless you and we'll see you
tomorrow.
>> Okay. Thank
>> All right. Thank you so much everybody
for joining us. And yes, I did promise
Doc that I would get him out of here 10
minutes prior. So, because he does have
another program to get you on to. And if
I could get my co-hosts on the screen
with me, I would greatly appreciate it.
I could not do this without them as
they're fielding the questions that are
coming in to the Zoom here in the Zoom
room with us out on the different social
platforms and emails and text messages.
Folks,
we are truly blessed with people who are
finally waking up and wanting to know
what they can do on their own to not
mask symptoms with chemicals, but
actually give their body what it needs
so that it can have a fighting chance to
be the best that it absolutely can be.
Thank you so much Marilyn for your
questions that you bring in as well as
all the typing that you are doing in the
chat and making sure that the dictation
is there so people can see clearly and
black and white what it is that Dr.
Wallik is recommending including the
correct spellings folks. So you do a
fantastic job at that Marilyn. Thank
you. And Sherry, thank you so much also
for fielding in those questions, helping
let people in, monitoring all the things
that you do. I greatly appreciate you as
well. and Albert doing the same from way
down south in South Africa. Um, with
this I call him, you know, Jeffrey the
giraffe or
he just this is this this giraffe folks
is massive. I've seen so many videos of
him. It's just unbelievable. Right in
your own front yard. But folks, no
matter where you are,
nutrition helps. And when it comes to
nutrients helping, we've got AJ, who is
nutrients help,
my assistant to the production manager,
who helps make sure everything is
connected, gets all the descriptions in,
make sure that all of the hashtags are
there so that when people are looking,
they will find us. So, thank you so
much, AJ, for all that you do. And, you
know, we want to thank Ruth Ellen
because she trained him how to do it.
And while she's on her vacation, we just
want to make sure that she doesn't have
to worry about a thing. And yes, folks,
she will be back shortly. So, thank you
everybody for investing time in
yourself, in joining us. Make sure that
you share this program with others.
there is somebody out there that is
hurting and searching and you sharing
this information will help them find
some solutions that they may have never
never seen before. So, we want to make
sure that you are doing your part
because you're not here by accident. I
don't believe any in any coincidences.
You're here for a purpose. And we want
to thank you for sharing our program
with others as we have a giveaway that
is going on. Go to dwdgiveaway.com.
That's DWD like daily withdoc just
short. DWDgiveaway.com.
Register for the giveaway. But there's a
part that's not just click all the
different platforms. you actually have
to go out to the platform and follow or
subscribe on that platform
in order to get the actual points for
the competition. So, we do verify those
things and if we're not able to verify
that you have actually completed the
different steps, then we go to the next
person, you know, when we're looking at
the rankings of the rewards points. So,
thank you again for joining us here. Get
back with the person that shared this
program with you. If there's nobody to
thank, I
give you a personal invitation to give
us a call at 855-9493377
or go to our website dailywithdoc.com.
use the contact option and you'll be
able to reach out to us and we'll get
you hooked up with a certified holistic
health coach to help you find out figure
out what is the best protocol to reach
your health goals. And folks, we have a
store on our website also. Click on shop
and you will find all of the products
that Dr. Wallik recommends in our store
that'll help you. So you give the body
what it needs, the body can do some
amazing things, folks. The products
themselves,
they don't do anything but nutrient the
body and give the raw ingredients that
the body then can do what it's designed
to do. Until next time, my name is Becca
Diggs. Bye for now.
Peace.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Heat. Heat.
>> [music]